Bora Bora Bora Bora Big Poppa this is a
half ball team to Geneva I'm is
interesting - we haven't seen that that
much of this character I feel like
people are really everybody was like yo
I can't wait for Geneva to come out and
then like it's a ghost town a week later
right like nobody stuck for this
character yeah people were really hype
on him you know what I'll never forget
is I was doing my podcast for a while
and I had lights on one time and I would
always ask people what character would
you put in the game if you could have
them run and his was Geneva really yeah
yeah his was he wanted Geneva that's
interesting yeah it's true I'm just
surprised like how many people were like
yo Geneva main day one and then gone
like net never to be seen again
I love to it hurts you when we first saw
him everyone thought like we were big
Geneva but nope he's here he's pick
fighting game players are this money
because as soon as the thing showed up
it's like all Jeanette was getting fuzzy
that's like all that everybody had to
know yeah I thought people already take
the picture that came from the jump
magazine yeah Rolly and they're like
well he can be fuzzy yeah it's fun
but already some work being made here
from Regina
yeah I'm gonna pick a level up look into
the dragon yeah yeah you put it into the
dragon prize not a good thought again
mrs. Kralik hard to beat here against
the leveled up Gohan yeah a lot of
hourly damage on this
still have to go guys
man this is rough buddy
last time Alucard block law this time
overhead
snap out again playing upset but uh I
feel like that is the appropriate thing
to do sparking and this is going to give
out in part a little bit of an advantage
here get set up with a piece it's that
DP through while the sparking just mana
there anyway bye doesn't end up
mattering it's gonna be a big man here
back dashes flips out for the level one
yeah
Detroit's my heart I think
it's so slow that is one of the issues
with it right it's like even if the
track tips like it takes a while to come
out in general
wait for was actually on the dragon rose
first I believe so also but it is he
doesn't get his nearby go Gino
there are five bars on deck for big but
Jackson I think I think you said yeah
does that mean spent a level great hair
for sure to get the knock down yeah
sparking anymore elbow drop I thought
maybe was gonna spend a level one this
time for sure and we saw that in his
last game that we saw and he just goes
to the elbow drop he sees a necessary to
kill yeah
all right that one else to be teleport
Wow that job age
and it goes regular brush I didn't tuck
that yeah that was brutal
two meters
it's enough oh man big but Jackson
already just freeze the left for Alec
cards the rough spot to be doesn't get
the bounce either on the vanish pool
track the super - booth keeps it it's
not gonna happen
you go PETA sounds a great confirm off
of it to you here - over excellent Wow
stop walking there though yeah that's
that's gonna be the killer
easy easy no extra meter
[Music]
and Alucard is the detention spot to has
the ability to at level 3 and be a stew
or you can go to golden this is this is
ala carte bets character so if he's
going to make a comeback with somebody
it's probably gonna be Frieza we're
trying to sending it to chase
no reflect you got to see if people are
going to reflect against your strengths
as a Frieza player for sure I keep
sweating right now
so both players keep making like really
close calls to each other Wow super -
managed to beat it what I was playing
weight off that rock man
yeah Nuala car was gonna let it rip
super nasty beat it
[Music]
yeah we're gonna snap let's bring it go
come on go on and definitely a problem
almost got it there oh my god hit by
that I wouldn't be generous like that or
something like URI raised right now but
you are erased fell apart whoa yeah even
if that Lakes itself didn't kill there
was like 60% left that is a hugely
damaging slaughter one big but Jackson
takes it working all over the screen
oh boy taking a tick Brook like the fine
man Alucard isn't a bad boy you could
tell that like just the way the vent is
spiraling out of control already this is
why it got a laugh these characters
unfortunately even though you don't
think you're really gonna run it to them
or you think they're that good yet you
don't know the matchup you are going to
get rocked by it and even if you have
laughs like what the crowd here you know
and just like here that's part you gonna
get the man throat is really good
honestly is very good commander I think
our part is vanishing out baby is
expecting that the canal is going to
clown
get it though there we go yeah Artie you
can super - go slide knocked out
but puts its up the corner you hate to
see it you hate to see it
[Music]
down level 3 now the question is is
there Sparky beer right I mean DT Goku's
left all the reflect but even a little
late on the age I like to change in the
freezer
[Music]
good check on that Grosso saved down the
parks getting hit
yeah I don't agree to that the throw is
probably gonna come out giving up the
disk we're still coming
I'll back out of there try again no
great goodness fit but Jackson is just
on a roll right now going again with the
level three with dad
sparking available again for our car
yes horse out blossom this time holds
the vanish super - chases
geneticist Alec cars running out in this
one ones walking already so it's got him
out of that position but he hasn't
really got too much out of it hold it
the tag in the genera I like this I'm
gonna see if such a netbook work
Oh we'll get them at the grab doesn't
get a pounce on it though that should be
in anyway yeah one more bar for the kill
okay this could be the momentum switch
that outer part needs to continue to
survive here and not get such the losers
bracket that super - in is gonna be a
good look tell you the knockdown off of
there another potential setup here and
before Jackson all transport install
right which is you know chilling in a
good spot to use dragon rushes have been
super successful we two bottles of wine
[Music]
now we're all tied up I mean a huge life
lead for a big-budget accident and you
have the sparking stones are not looking
so great here for Alucard doesn't
presents is a great assist does kind of
make you have to suffer but put that
jump back jump back oh this is gonna be
the kill knock down the last hit kill no
meaner spent two characters in sparking
verses Frieza Alucard this is a real
real tough ass at least go gold yes a
meter 2 amps trying to expect a star but
not really a lot to be to keep it up
after a little prayer anything just
knocked down fades a DB not surprised
but it miss put an extent with the 5h
though that's the only downside to that
oh good guard cancel out yeah now you
also have to be mindful of the commandos
as well this command zonal level 3 is
gonna do a lot of damage
Russell super - six amp reflective okay
I like this getting the extension
therefore getting back to the corner
please don't harvest and a really big
meter disadvantage right now thought the
plates want to be but that dragon brush
is gonna build a little bit of bark one
and that's gonna be the end of the
cheetah yeah that's a huge kill right
because now there's no sparking left got
a really even game you know Jackson has
a lot of meters so you have to be
careful any hit and the level three is
gonna be a kill even like a roll of a
prairie reaction yeah I thought he was
gonna get that punish on that yeah
Kalakaar it's gonna happen three closer
there at the end of this air - back in
stagger the guard can Sylvanus is it
here this could be the comeback Alec
Park needs just got very careful here
again this Goku's try the 2h over all
the way back was so low
Freeza the crowd is popping off right
now the funny thing is that the crowd
was all against them at first right like
they're all rooting for big but Jackson
yeah here we go and then has that
comeback was happening they're like now
Jota this is like crazy fries that come
back it's hard not to root for him final
game between these two top 32 qualifier
here Puerto Rico
early confirm off the freezer sir I just
wanted to get a June if a level three so
we can say drop me I love that I love
all the meats that came from it there's
there and everywhere like not even just
in fight here slide knock down no break
that has been a big issue for Alucard at
this that for sure I feel like you know
you were talking about the lab game just
so immense drag of Russia's coming from
big but Jackson yeah I mean it's out
there running there I mean if it's work
and it's working right here - over
alochol with the block
Barkha this is gonna hurt his Frieza I
don't know who's gonna be quite enough
to kill with that damage it's gonna be a
big chunk here okay
countess barks lost like 80% still
reflect got is huge
give me at that freezes sparking running
out now but why the level three gotta
love these animations God love these
animations blast it and this is that
character that put in so much work for
Alucard Lasky made that comeback now out
of here it's Geneva Duty gokula that
have to be very careful here luckily
Sparky has gone on both sides
[Music]
Albert gets hit like that though it gets
hit this time the auto calm over the
extension too
Peters
Louisville ones one more to get the job
done
there's only up the GT Goku hearing
things do not look very great for
Alucard could be seeing the losers side
after this to end starter debt no
sparking no other characters even what
you want to do like Spirit Bomb here you
have to sell yourself set it up like
that spend the extra meter gamma
yeah that's over really really high
break because a great tack there from
Jacob Jackson taxi to go cheetah
gar cancel me scary
that's lost that's a big punish but it
worked out okay
yeah reflects looking for those gaps
advantages out of there I thought he was
gonna maybe get punished for that but
get that 2h there
yeah not down at the corner
I take a level up again dragon rush
got to be careful to em could be in here
yeah I don't we're trying to get out of
that he built the bar from it I don't
know we're gonna see it go through
abstention here no no but they go oh in
the elbow drop does it beat but Jackson
over Alec are from and alive defending
the turkey route is going nuts all right
it's top thirty two qualifier and
they're clapping it up from the crowd
that was a good one that was a good